Speaker 1: So this is just absolutely fascinating.
You may remember this Democratic congresswoman,
former Democratic congresswoman named Tulsi
Gabbard, who really had a faction of the left
like two or two percent.
Basically, two percent of the left was absolutely
enamored with her, and she would use terms
like regime change and endless wars in order
to sort of convince people, I guess, that
she was like, maybe on the left.
But the truth was much of what she said was
always reactionary.
And since leaving Congress after her completely
failed presidential bid, she's really become
a darling of the right, appearing regularly
on Fox News.
She's going to be speaking at CPAC, which
will get to a little bit later.
And this is almost beyond parody.
Tulsi appeared last night with Sean Hannity,
and her take on the Russia Ukraine situation
was so outrageous, so unhinged, so unabashedly
pro-Russia that propagandist Sean Hannity
had to pump the brakes and say, Hey, hold
on a second.
Putin has had these territorial ambitions
for a very long time here.
It's not just about security.
Tulsi appearing and saying, Oh, what Putin's
doing is that he's protecting Russia.
What he's doing is for their security, and
Hannity has to be like, Listen, Putin has
had these these territorial ambitions for
a long time and says Ukraine is not even a
country when Hannity makes more sense than
Tulsi.
You know, she's nuts.
Take a look at this ending
Speaker 2: the world that we live in and not
the world that maybe some people wished existed.
And that reality is Putin has made very clear
all along that their security in his mind
is what's at stake here and they do not want.
I don't want to interrupt us.
And NATO's also
Speaker 5: said Ukraine is not a country.
And he has been saying this going back many,
many years.
So this has been these two ambitions have
existed
Speaker 2: already, component.
They have.
They go way back and they preexisted.
Speaker 1: I love it.
Is it?
I want to focus on the security component,
right?
Because that's the component that's that's
interesting to you.
She is so unhinged that Hannity has to say,
Hey, Tulsi, there's kind of like other realities
here that you're not living in.
And I'm going to try to pull you back towards
them.
Like Hannity saying, you're pro-Russian propaganda
is a bit too much.
This is when a friend would be like, Tulsi,
you might want to sit this one out when Hannity
has to slow you down.
And of course it is is once again a reminder
of all the people that got bamboozled by a
Gabbard into thinking she's she's some kind
of she's speaking truth to power, or she's
she's on the left.
She's a true progressive.
The last real liberal or whatever.
And it listen, Hillary Clinton is not likable,
and it's very popular to dislike Hillary Clinton.
But when Hillary said maybe Russians are grooming
Tulsi for a third party run, I don't think
Hillary was literally correct.
But Hillary's instincts about Tulsi were completely
right.
I mean, it is.
At the end of the day, I actually wonder,
does Tulsi believe this stuff?
Or does she just want attention?
Is this a character that she's playing?
You know, we've speculated that Candace Owens,
for example, is not really this ignorant right
wing loon that it's more of a character she's
developed for for profit.
We've wondered, did 40 year old, then 40 year
old Dave Rubin really go from being a Bernie
supporter to a Trump supporter through some
kind of a genuine political awakening?
Or was it because of the money that came attached
with saying I've quit being on the left?
I don't know.
I don't know if Tulsi believes this stuff
or is just saying it because it's developing
this profitable character for her.
I don't even know if it's profitable.
But what I can tell you for sure is that when
Hannity is slowing down, you're pro-Putin
propaganda and you're supposedly on the left.
You've really got to be evaluating sort of
like what positions you're staking out here.
And unfortunately, there are people who have
sort of woken up to the scam of.
Tulsi Gabbard of that, two percent of the
left that fell
for he